A Man’s Dreams - Scene Breakdown
In my last video I talked about the deeply
emotional and touching moment of liberation
that Nico Robin experienced at the top of
the tower of justice on Ennis Lobby.
And so today I think it’s just appropriate
to continue this elegantly emotional journey,
because -. Oh, sorry I think I just played
the wrong clip there.
As I was saying, what makes Robin’s character
feel so vulnerable and gentle is the - - Uhm.
So…what I really want to talk to you about
today is how seamlessly and delicately Oda
has designed her - Okay, you know what: Fine,
you’re right.
Nothing sentimental today.
Let’s talk Epic and Powerful.
Let’s talk about Blackbeard and why his
infamous speech on Jaya sets him up to be
my favourite villain in One Piece.
One of the things that being stuck in quarantine
made me realise - besides the fact that I
can staple exactly 19 rolls of toilet paper
to the ceiling of my bathroom - is how god
damn excited I am to see Luffy facing of Blackbeard
and his men towards the end of the story.
But at the same time, I’m also incredibly
scared what Blackbeard might do to Luffy before
they can face off in battle, like kidnapping
Robin or killing off Shanks.
And I slowly started going down the rabbit
hole of all the Blackbeard theories out there
and what he might end up doing in the story.
And so several YouTube videos, a slightly
too big can of coffee and a short panic attack
where I almost spilled same can of coffee
all across my laptop later, I finally found
myself confronted with the question of all
questions: How the hell do I love Blackbeard
so much as a villain, if he hasn’t even
properly clashed yet without our hero, expect
for a minor skirmish in Impel Down?
And the answer to this question is exactly
this moment here, in mock town on Jaya at
the beginning of the Skypea arc.
It’s an incredibly crafted scene by Oda,
filled to the brim with comedy, epicness and
action, that not only foreshadows a whole
lot of things to come in the story, but also
contains enormous symbolism for one of the
major themes of One Piece: Dreams.
So, while this might admittedly be a quite
harsh contrast to Robin’s moment on Ennis
Lobby, I think you will agree with me that
this scene definitely belongs into our ‘The
iconic scene analysis series’ ‘trademark’
, and so let’s break this moment down and
see what makes it tick.
As always I’ll be starting with a short
recap of the moment, that you can but really
shouldn’t skip by going to this timecode
here.
Also, if you wanna follow along with the manga
, we’ll be discussing chapter 223 ‘till
225 and episode 147 of the anime.
Let’s rolllllllll.
The scene takes place shortly after the crew
arrives on Jaya to investigate the way to
Skypea, of which they have found a map inside
a ship that had fallen from the sky.
After arriving in Mock Town, the main town
of the island, Nami makes Luffy and Zoro promise
to not fight and cause any commotion for them,
while they’re here, already foreshadowing,
that of course - there is going to be a commotion.
Shortly after leaving the ship, they encounter
three strange men, each of which will later
turn out to be part of Blackbeard’s crew:
The sniper Van Augur, who is shooting down
birds from a rooftop, the sickly Doc Q, who
is giving out explosive apples to strangers
as well as the wrestler Jesus Burgess, who
is taking out countless people on the street.
These three, quite unique and important seeming
figures aren’t revealed for who they TRULY
are until the straw hats leave for Skypea
however, leaving the readers wondering what
the hell they have just seen.
While wandering through the city, Luffy, Nami
and Zoro come across a fancy looking hotel
complex, however immediately after entering
they are told that the establishment is rented
out by the Bellamy pirates.
Moments later, one of Bellamy’s men appears,
taking them for vagabonds and throwing money
at them.
And The fact that Nami doesn’t take free
money, I think, speaks for itself here.
After the three straw hats leave, the pirate
finds out about Luffy’s bounty of 30M berry
and shares this information with his captain,
planning to take on Luffy - not knowing that
his bounty has already increased to a 100M.
Meanwhile, Luffy and Co enter one of the local
pubs in order to eat.
There Luffy sits next to a stuffy looking
man and for an entire hilarious sequence of
moments, both Luffy and the man share the
exact identical reactions, except that while
Luffy hates the food and loves the drinks,
the man feels exactly the opposite.
They start contending who can order the most
food and in general seem very similar to each
other.
Luffy is ready to brawl with the man, who
then asks him whether he is a pirate and doesn’t
believe Luffy when he says he has a 30 million
bounty on his head.
He then leaves the pub, just when Bellamy
and his men arrive.
Mirroring Shank’s encounter with the mountain
bandit Higuma, the scene begins with a false
sense of good-will, with Bellamy buying Luffy
a drink.
Before he can take a single zip however, Bellamy
smashes his head into the bar counter.
Before Bellamy can enjoy his undeniably brave
deed too much though, Zoro already has a blade
right at his throat.
Luffy also gets back to his feet, preparing
to fight Bellamy and Nami - trying to keep
their goal in mind - asks the barkeeper what
he knows about the sky islands, as they plan
to journey there.
At these words Bellamy and all of his men
gathered in the pub break into laughter.
Switching from laughing to suddenly angry,
Bellamy says that the age where pirates have
dreams is over, mentioning the city of gold,
the emerald capital and even the one piece,
and declares that a new age is coming.
Looking disgustedly at Luffy he says that
dreams are for losers.
At this moment something visibly changes in
Luffy and when Bellamy and his men start beating
them up, he tells Zoro not to do anything,
despite Nami’s pleads to fight back now,
falsely attributing their behaviour to their
earlier promise not to fight.
After bravely standing up to the pirates’
taunts herself, she finally drags the bloody
Luffy and zoro out of the pub, where in the
middle of the square, the scruffy man from
earlier is sitting who apparently decided
to witness the brawl.
He shouts at them that the sky islands are
real and tells Nami that Luffy and Zoro have
just won this fight.
In this moment, Luffy remembers Shanks and
Ace and their expectations in him to become
a great pirate.
The man meanwhile continues his epic speech,
saying that the age where pirates can dream
is not ending, because a man’s dream never
ends.
While the people around laugh at him, Luffy
and zoro stare back at him without saying
a word.
He tells Luffy that the road to the top isn’t
easy and that on the way there you come across
people who aren’t worth your fist and that
he hopes they will make it to the sky islands.
Without a response the straw hats leave and
when Nami wonders who he was, Luffy and Zoro
respond that it’s probably not him, but
them.
Later on we find out that this man was indeed
Blackbeard and that just like Bellamy, he
now has chosen Luffy as his target, however
for the exact opposite reason.
Okay so let’s dissect this bad boy of a
scene.
If you didn’t yet get yourself a cup of
coffee - or tea…*clears throat* - or you
need a refill, make sure that you’re well
supplied and make yourself comfortable, because
there is a lot to talk about in this video.
While this scene does a very solid work in
terms of body language, framing, etc., what
makes this scene truly stand out as an iconic
one piece moment in ‘The iconic scene analysis
series’ ‘trademark’ , is the enormous
amount of symbolism it carries.
So in this analysis I will focus heavily on
this aspect and mention other note-worthy
elements as we go along.
Okay, *cracking knuckles* so before we dive
into the two heavy themes of dreams and dichotomy
here, there is one small symbol I wanna talk
about first as a sort of warm-up: Mock Town.
Oda uses the name of the city here as a symbol
for the story-line itself, as Luffy, Zoro
and Nami are being mocked for their dreams
by Bellamy and his men and Bellamy is in turn
mocked by Blackbeard for not having a dream
in the first place.
Oda loves to play around with location names
like this, where for instance Louge town refers
to the words prologue and epilogue, as Roger’s
journey started and ended here and it also
marks the endpoint of the straw hats prologue
in the Eastblue before entering the Grand
Line.
And - careful very smooth transition incoming
- of course Luffy enters the Grand Line to
fulfil his Dream of becoming the freest man
in the world and find the One Piece - nailed
it!
Okay, let’s talk about a man’s dreams
- or a woman’s dreams I guess.
Actually, small fun fact, when you read the
Japanese original, Blackbeard simply says
人の夢は終わらねエ！
Literally meaning ‘a person’s dream never
ends!’
So depending on the translation you’ve read
I might just blown your mind.
Or not.
Moving on.
I hope we’re all on the same page when I
say that dreams are one of, if not THE biggest
theme in One Piece.
It for sure is the theme of Luffy and his
crew and it also seems to play an important
role for the members of the D. Family, a topic
that deserves an entire separate video on
its own.
Dreams are the underlying driver of this entire
scene here on Jaya and play a role in all
the major events surrounding it.
Let’s start with Luffy’s encounter with
Bellamy and his men first.
The fundamental question in this moment is
- why do Luffy and Zoro not fight back here?
The easiest answer here would of course be
that they promised Nami not to cause a commotion
and they simply want to stay true to their
promise.
However, Luffy was clearly prepared to brawl
with Blackbeard over nothing more than food
earlier and if we look at this panel here,
after Luffy gets back up, he also clearly
is ready to fight Bellamy, just as Zoro is
ready - having his sword at Bellamy’s throat.
However after he and his men laugh at Nami
for asking about the Sky islands and claiming
that the era where pirates can dream is over
and that fantasies like the golden city, the
emerald capital or the One piece are not worth
pursuing, Luffy suddenly seams to loose interest
in him.
Why then was Luffy ready to fight Blackbeard
but not Bellamy?
Now you might be tapping your fingers thinking:
“Ohara my man, obviously Luffy didn’t
fight him, because Shanks didn’t fight the
bandits either back in Fusha village!”
And, I think you’re definitely right in
that this moment with Shanks plays an important
role here.
However, I think there is a lot more to it.
The reason Shanks didn’t fight back against
Higuma and his men was his pacifistic philosophy,
that basically goes something like this: “If
there is no need to fight and no imminent
danger to my life or that of my friends, there
is no need for needless violence.”
Shanks was obviously lightyears out of Higuma’s
reach and as long as he only tried to humiliate
him, there was no real need to respond to
this and lower yourself to their level.
The same goes for Luffy in this situation.
He knows that he is stronger than Bellamy,
which he proves later on in the story, and
even though he and Zoro actually get physically
harmed, Bellamy wasn't standing in the way
of Luffy's goals or had hurt any of his friends,
at least yet, and so there was no real need
to fight back.
Only when Bellamy beats up Mont Blanc Noland
and takes away his gold, does Luffy come back
and beat Bellamy with one single punch, just
as Shanks took out all of the bandits once
they laid hands on Luffy.
Luffy wants to become a great pirate like
Shanks and Ace and so reacting in the same
way as his mentor shows the character development
he has gone through since that moment in the
bar, where kid Luffy was furious for Shanks’
behaviour - which I think is also shows the
confidence he has in his own powers.
So yes, the reference to Shanks is obviously
very much intentional here and there is a
reason that Luffy sees both him and Ace before
his eyes during Blackbeard’s speech and
we’ll actually get back to this later on
as this might have a second meaning as well.
However, if this attitude was the only reason
Luffy didn’t fight, why the hell did he
raise his fists in the first place?
I think that there is another criterium after
which Luffy decides whether or not someone
is worth fighting, next to whether they are
a threat or not.
After all there are a number of fights that
Luffy seems to truly enjoy and cherish.
And this criterium is: A dream.
Does the person standing in front of him have
a dream?
A will to fight for what he believes in?
And is he striving to fulfil this dream no
matter what?
Blackbeard clearly does have a dream and so
Luffy is more than willing to brawl with him
and takes him for full.
The same goes for Burgess, who challenges
everyone in the streets a little earlier,
stating that he’s the champion.
Luffy and zoro want to fight him right away.
The Blackbeard pirates, just like the straw
hats all have their own dream and will they
follow, no matter how much they might be polar
to each other in terms of values and morality.
What Bellamy does when laughing at their wish
to find the Sky Island and spitting on the
era of pirates dreaming, is a clear sign for
Luffy that this man has no dream and thus
no will of his own.
Thus he is not on the same level as him and
since he is no immediate threat, he is not
worth fighting.
As Zoro confirms, when asked by Nami about
this later, Luffy felt nothing but pity for
Bellamy in this moment, who is used and disregarded
by the man he admires.
Doflamingo being a celestial dragon and thus
the arch-nemesis of those that have dreams,
is wonderfully set up in this moment by Oda,
and the pity that Luffy feels for the dream
and will-less Bellamy is something that he
beautifully references again on Dressrosa,
when Luffy calls Bellamy his friend and ultimately
wants to free him from Doflamingo’s control.
And so, the only reason Luffy finally goes
back to fight Bellamy is because he knows
that the gold city is Mont Blanc’s dream,
and by stealing his gold, the only proof that
held the old man’s dream together, Bellamy
had mocked this dream as well and taken it
away.
Luffy might be naive and and a bit slow on
the uptake sometimes, but his sense for what
is pure is incredible.
He believes in friendship, dreams, and dying
for what you believe in.
This is just one way Oda illustrates that
for us, but I think it’s really hard to
see that if you don’t believe in dreams
yourself.
The entire theme of dreams then goes full
circle.
Before leaving for Skypea and after knocking
out Bellamy, one of his men asks Luffy where
he is going, to which Luffy replies “Showing
that nothing can stop him from following his
dreams.
Finally, after defeating Enel, Luffy rings
the golden bell of Sandora and his Shadow
can be seen in the sky by Noland and his men.
Thus, Luffy has confirmed that the golden
city actually exists, legitimising his dream
and opposing Bellamy’s initial mocking of
both their dreams.
Okay, let’s talk about Blackbeard.
As you might have realised, Blackbeard directly
references Roger’s last words here with
his speech.
Whether or not he was actually present at
Roger’s funeral, what Oda pretty much foreshadows
with this parallel here, is that Blackbeard
is also a D. Just like Luffy and Roger, he
his driven by his dream, which involves finding
the One piece.
Of course, whatever his dream might be, it
is most likely a lot more self-centred than
Luffy’s, but it is without any doubt true
that both characters share an insane amount
of similarities.
And so, this is the second big theme of this
scene: Dichotomy - or to be more precise the
dichotomy between Blackbeard and Luffy.
Let’s look at their first encounter in the
bar.
Both of them are eating, one loves the pie
and hates the lemonade whereas the other thinks
the contrary.
It shows just how perfectly opposed they are
- they think the same way but have perfectly
opposed point of view on what’s good and
what’s bad.
The framing wonderfully supports this impression
as both are shown side to side for several
panels and it seems very deliberate by Oda,
who’s basically telling us “yeah these
guys are gonna be rivals”.
Blackbeard is, what writers call a foil - a
character who shares many of the same traits
and characteristics as the main character,
but differs in one critical way, and is usually
set against him.
Luffy and Teach are similar in many core ways,
and started their journey in similar fashion.
Coming from humble beginnings, the story builds
these characters up over time, showing their
struggles, their limits, and how they overcome
these obstacles to grow to greater heights.
They both understand the need for teamwork
and have a very simple, goal-driven mindset.
However, whereas Luffy gains strength and
infamy through courage, justice and honest
ambition, Teach advances through deception,
murder and the exploitation of the weakness
of others.
Despite their shared attitude that dreams
can never be given up on, the dichotomy of
their methods resonates with this story arc.
And so, bringing the conversation back to
the theme of dreams, you could say that Blackbeard
chose the 'easy' way to achieve his dreams,
since he did what was necessary, but not what
was right.
Luffy in contrast will achieve his dreams
WITH his crew mates and most likely they are
even an active part of his dream in the first
place.
And I think it’s almost poetic that Blackbeard
doesn’t actually sleep.
In other words, he doesn’t even have real
dreams to begin with.
This is so - The way Oda introduces Teach
in this scene by the way might be my favourite
introduction of any villain ever.
First of all I think for all the issues I
have had with the One Piece anime over the
years, the casting of Blackbeard’s Voice
Actor, might have been the best thing they
every came up with, Akio Ōtsuka.
That man simply has the perfect range of voice
for this character and I love every line he
says.
And the way that the iconic panel itself simply
blows out the entire background and noise
around them, sousing solely on Blackbeard
opposing the three straw hats is wonderful
visual foreshadowing for the future conflict
between the two, but also the similarity between
them.
And speaking of foreshadowing, the way Luffy
sees Ace and Shanks before his eyes, makes
me wonder whether this is some sort of foreshadowing
as well.
Ace has already been taken out by Blackbeard,
and Shanks also has a special relationship
with him.
Some food for thought.
What is also interesting is how Luffy’s
and also Zoro’s attitude changes towards
Blackbeard and how their words to Nami have
given rise to a number of wild speculations
about Blackbeard’s powers.
I don’t wanna dev into these too much, but
simply from an analysis perspective I think
it becomes clear that Luffy sees another person
siting in the square than who he saw in the
pub.
This Blackbeard here is not the Blackbeard
that sat next to him eating pie.
And so Luffy just stares at him, making clear
that he can’t be fooled.
This reaction might also ultimately have been
the reason that Blackbeard decided to take
Luffy out, fearing that he might become his
greatest rival chasing the One Piece.
Okay, so what is the overall purpose of this
scene?
As mentioned at the beginning of this video,
yes that was like 4 hours ago, this scene
is packed to the brim with symbolism.
The scene works strongly with the overarching
theme of dreams, that is also reflected in
the introduction of Luffy’s main antagonist
in the story.
The way Oda introduces Blackbeard is refreshingly
creative, since our first impressions of Blackbeard
come to us from the stories we hear about
him prior to his official introduction.
We know that he scared Wapol badly enough
to cause him to abandon Drum Island and that
Ace is hunting him because he killed a fellow
shipmate.
Okay.
It shouldn’t be too hard to identify this
ruthless pirate, right?
When we are first introduced to the man we
would later come to know as Blackbeard, the
first thing he does is get into a fight with
Luffy about whether the cherry pie tastes
good or bad.
This guy feels important to us, but certainly
not in a bad way.
Only at the end of the scene do we learn the
truth about who we just met.
This is a truly fantastic moment in the story
that without any doubt deserves a spot in
our list.
While Luffy and Blackbeard got a whole lot
of character development in this scene, who
also deserves some praise here I feel was
Zoro, who stood next to his captain and took
the beating without any complaint.
How did Zoro become such a loyal partner for
Luffy?
We will be looking at that in the next video.
Thanks guys.
Peace.